I can't decide which which was my
favorite jab whether it was Raina saying
it's a pleasure to welcome yet another
deputy prime minister to the dispatch
box the third Deputy I faced in three
years third time's a charm or if it was
Dad and saying kissed armor and Angela
Raynor are the fill in Holly of British
politics oh give me give me Phil and
Holly any day of the week my God that
was painful I mean lame gags kind of
weak jibes over long questions somebody
edit the edit those questions down
because it was one of those premises
questions you know with the deputies
where the deputies didn't do the deputy
title that much Justice I'm sad to say
there was one thing and one thing only I
thought was interesting about that
premise of questions it was the one at
the end and it was the exchange between
the ex-cabinet minister Simon Clark and
Oliver Dowden now uh viewers might have
seen some of the reporting in the last
few days around questions around what's
going on in t-sides now the conservative
t Valley mayor there has come into
questions about quite how a development
in the area has been conducted and
there's an interesting question for how
the Downing Street and how the
government machine respond to this and
what's absolutely clear is that Oliver
down I'm sure he's speaking for
Richardson is going to stand shoulder to
shoulder with Ben Houchin the teas
Valley mayor and they made that
absolutely clear so there's going to be
a fight a political fight about what
happened in t-side and Downing Street
right now think that the politics of
this is all in doubling down and
standing with him in the face of lots of
questions no proven allegations but lots
of questions and lots of calls for
inquiries okay
um so something to watch uh looking at
how Dan did in the round I mean I've
never seen him so animated how do you
think he did
um you got to see why Oliver Dowden was
for the last five prime ministers the
backroom guy supplying the lines you
know there were some quite uh
interesting lines there the one about um
uh conservatives stop uh the boats labor
rig votes worth pointing out labor
actually walked back from their plan to
uh give EU Nationals the vote in general
elections that's not part of their uh
plan uh at the moment but what I think
is interesting and worth a lot of
scrutiny is when Oliver Dowden throws in
uh facts about the economy so he said
fastest growth rate in the G7 now we've
been fact checking that during the
premises questions yes if you look at
the figure annually if you look at the
2020 uh one or 2022 figures that is true
in comparison to Canada France Germany
Italy Japan and the us but when you look
at the quarter on quarter growth
actually the UK is doing uh pretty
abysmally it's the second worst
um Ed Conway our economics editor calls
it total nonsense to boast about
um the fastest growth rate in the GDP
growth in the G7 if you're actually
talking about uh actually the slowest so
be careful what you wish for it depends
what time period uh Oliver Dowden is
talking about you have to listen really
hard when they make claims about the
economy in the end I think viewers will
know whether they think the British
economy is doing well or badly